so something that I find so interesting
about both of you that between this and
Tiger you good nights and the movies you
guys do together is that they're all
very focused on just pure an ironic man
love it's it's it's it's very real
friendship just between guys and I'm
wondering what draws you to that and why
that's an important thing well we're
both guys and we're both friends so our
movies tend to be about guys who are our
friends and I do think I do think it's
kind of an underrepresented thing like
what really goes on in male friendships
the sensitivity and the vulnerability
and all that stuff we kind of just like
think of men's friendships as being like
slaps on the back and just drinking
beers but a lot of intense stuff guys as
it pertains to you know the works of
Sherlock Holmes I don't their comrades
their associates it's assumed they're
friends but I don't know if they ever
have moments where they're like you're
my dear friend and so to explore that
and you know obviously it's a comedy but
I think we found that interesting so I
don't want to I don't wanna give away
too much but there is a very large
musical number yes in this film that
baby was so it was just so good that I
was like maybe this movie should have
just been a musical I'm wondering what
the what the process was like for that
number and was there rehearsals was
those you guys have to harass that was
well yeah we gotta compress a whole
revelation that Jacques has about
himself in his emotional life and you
know and that you know that could have
taken a long time but it's the way we
compressed it into a musical number you
kind of get through a lot of information
and a really funny and entertaining way
and it's sort of like a almost like a
montage but with more information maybe
the maybe the next movie should be music
so he's putting out there and should be
we should we would relish that are you
kidding me
story should we turn into a musical yeah
be funny Titanic
that's height anti-tank is in this movie
I'm just thinking of one that we haven't
seen before
maybe Orville and Wilbur Wright the
musical yes so when you do it the idea
starts here I'm sorry I still have paper
why do you have paper in your mouth
because I ate a question it's that's
fine I accept that as previous so to uh
to celebrate Holmes and Watson I'd like
to do a lightning round of riddles for
you guys okay to start off what can
travel around the world while staying in
a corner travel around the world a right
angle that's fair that's not wrong the
answer is a stamp a stem oh yeah
okay that's that's good one though I'm
taller your lightning around yes yeah
the first thing that comes to mind yeah
you can cut us off we're taking too long
what gets wetter and wetter the more it
dries come on
lightning round lightning round wetter
weather the more dry but the cactus
correct no it's not what what what is it
it's a towel a towel yeah okay all right
I'm getting wrapped up I got so much my
kids will love them yeah I actually did
get these from a kid riddle
yeah the kids love the riddles because
then they try to shoot then they get the
riddle from the dad and then they then
they lord over their friends yeah
you